- Emma steht um halb sieben auf.
Danach putzt sie Zähne.
Das ist wichtig, Emma, okay?
- Ich putze immer meine Zähne!
- Immer oder manchmal?
- Fast immer.
- Okay …
Äh, zum Frühstück isst Emma
normalerweise Müsli mit Milch.
Aber manchmal isst sie auch einen Apfel.
Und zum Mittagessen gibt es oft Gemüse.
- Gemüse?
- Ja, Gemüse.
Tomaten, Salat, Brokkoli.
Mittagessen gibt es um zwölf.
Von zwei bis drei Uhr macht Emma
normalerweise Hausaufgaben.
Und von vier bis halb fünf übt sie Flöte.
Ich kontrolliere das!
- Ja ja …
- Und du siehst nicht fern.
Und nach dem Spielen räumst du auf.
Ich möchte hier kein Chaos haben!
- Kein Problem.
- Ich weiß.
- Morgen ist ein super Tag!
- Danke, Nico!
Ich bin morgen gegen sechs zum
Abendessen wieder zu Hause.